I never seemed like I wonder where those
are I really don't know it looks amazing
it's incredible it's so hot though
seriously I'm something to sweat just
big your hair for like two seconds I'm
here for the social star awards we're
gonna have a rehearsal today and I think
that's it that's all I got to do so it's
pretty sweet we're gonna it's a golf
course down there I have never been a
hotel this luxurious that is crazy in
our own town I am so happy the flight
was like it was like the biggest chairs
I have seen in my entire life and I've
seen the big chairs
I feel so lost what am I worried be
doing here you feel crazy but yeah it's
gonna be cool it's gonna be a fun fun
week or a fun couple days rather
I rose it's 7:00 in the morning here in
Singapore and I am here at the pool
it's amazing I have pretty pretty good
um I I'm just kind of like a famous pool
I'm sure wasn't seen it ah let me go to
the edge I can't complain right now even
though I'm really jet-lagged I can't
complain
I think I should end this before I drop
drop your rosin water anyway see ya
look at this she's more beautiful at
night I just went down to the lobby of
the hotel my car didn't work so I just
went down and there's like a hundred
fans down there and it just started
screaming when I came in like what it's
so crazy I had no idea I had this very
fancy Singapore it really shocked me I
was like what's going on I just want to
go to the lobby and then there's like
anyway that was fun
impossible he can can't be happy after
something like that so I am waiting to
go downstairs that mean ups
I'm leaving soap yeah an elderly man
enjoys some empathy hey how are you look
at that look at I look at my just
kidding look at me hey don't drop the
phone don't drop oh now we're going to
the edge Oh No look at this face so I
mean this is background and so beautiful
oh my god good thing there anyway don't
[ __ ] come here come here
I don't know this sounds like any more
buying to make it up
dun dun dun dun they're done and
relevant inform them that other than the
bank wide I left my hand now I can touch
Rick end this vlog I'm gonna end this
vlog my tongue
to the very first social star or
I don't even know what threw it out
right
hi I defend ya
I don't know what I'm looking at what I
like
Oh
you
I was intense oh yeah my ears are
bleeding